for 2.5 million years the Earth's
climate has fluctuated cycling from ice
ages to warmer periods but in the last
century the planets temperature has
risen unusually fast about 1.2 to 1.4
degrees Fahrenheit scientists believe
it's human activity that's driving the
temperatures up a process known as
global warming
ever since the industrial revolution
began factories power plants and
eventually cars have burned fossil fuels
such as oil and pole releasing huge
amounts of carbon dioxide and other
gases into the atmosphere these
greenhouse gases trap heat near the
earth through a naturally occurring
process called the greenhouse effect the
greenhouse effect begins with the Sun
and the energy it radiates to the earth
the earth and the atmosphere absorbs
some of this energy while the rest is
radiated back into space
naturally-occurring gas is in the
atmosphere trap some of this energy and
reflected back warming the earth
scientists now believe that the
greenhouse effect is being intensified
by the extra greenhouse
that humans have released evidence for
global warming includes a recent string
of very warm ears scientists report that
1998 was the warmest year in measured
history with 2005 coming in second
meanwhile readings taken from ice cores
show that the greenhouse gases carbon
dioxide and methane have hit their
highest levels in the past 420 thousand
years Arctic sea ice is also shrinking
according to NASA studies the extent of
Arctic sea ice has declined about 10
percent in the last 30 years as long as
industrialized nations consume energy
and developing countries increase their
fossil fuel consumption the
concentration of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere will continue to rise
researchers predict that temperatures
will increase about 2 to 10 degrees
Fahrenheit by the end of the century
what's less certain is what rising
temperatures mean for the planet some
climate models predict subtle changes
others forecast rising sea levels which
could flood coastal areas around the
world weather patterns could change
making hurricanes more frequent severe
droughts could become more common in
warm areas and species unable to adapt
to the changing conditions would face
extinction although much remains to be
learned about global warming
many organizations advocate cutting
greenhouse gas emissions to reduce the
impact of global warming
consumers can help by saving energy
around the house
switching to compact fluorescent
lightbulbs and driving fewer miles in
the car and tweet these simple changes
may help keep the earth cooler in the
future